por lá então colocar o nosso ovo na
frigideira em 321 batel de pessoal de
quem fala dar que sejam muito bem vindos
a mais um vídeo e peguei só agora que o
canal não conhece eu sou da área e eu
tenho uma sobrinha chamada barbie bobsin
também tem outra cabine chamado bob
acabar e podem tanto bem ao cantar maior
controle busto da loja antes você não
quer falar com você
só se for em nova york no final já se
inscrevam já deixei muito líquido neste
vídeo porque hoje nós vamos ter aqui um
experimento muito interessante que eu
sempre quis fazer em casa eu agora tenho
essa oportunidade por tá muito calor
aqui muito calor ser obviamente que nós
condenamos a praia está muito calor
obviamente contamos assim mais para o
interior do país também está muito calor
mas é que nesta zona onde eu estou a
viver agora nunca teve um calor assim
sério em santo 37 graus e muita gente
deve estar habituado a este calor mas eu
não boto jatos o ataque do milan enfim
só que nós vamos fazer hoje onde nós
vamos testar fritar um ovo nessa ideia
no asfalto na estrada ou não uma pedra
no concreto celular mas gente quer
mostrar o que anda acontecendo aqui
nadar com hollande porque muita coisa
acontecendo aqui principalmente um jeito
de incluir este calor o que atrai atrai
mosquitos atrai mel que atrai música
atrair tudo o que é bicho podre e tudo o
que é bicho fifa acaba por morrer é
porque encontrei que já uma série de
animais morte e complicada complicada e
eu vou te mostrar o que eu encontrei
ontem aqui no jardim que eu acho que um
rato morto e espero que não seja assim
tão gráfico é porque não quer mostrar
coisas horrendas mas eu também tô
curioso então vamos ver junto o que
coloca pessoal eu acho que é mais rápido
não só o talento de wagadu anne isso
porque essa coisa que eu adoro e atinge
custa muito ver que o ratinho horto
méxico infelizmente eu não consegui
ajudar e agora vamos mostrar-lhe o
plantão porque eu quero fazer a mesma
coisa eu não sei se vocês já viram
larvas do mosquito mas os kits e
mosquitos são larvas e essas larvas são
colocadas sempre na água limpa de coisas
assim não sei se vocês vão conseguir ver
mas tem que muita coisa na água o cheiro
olhei olhei eduardo uns quito onde isso
tem uma grande lei
já que é isso o dark uma larva do
mosquito e sem ingerir menos vão ficar
sá não pessoal é de frente larva do
mosquito é isto e gerindo é isto é
completamente diferente
sim porque no início até pensei que
atingir índice tornam sapos mas não é
mesmo espírito é muito pouco então eu
acho que vou ter que tirar a água toda a
planta que não vai mexer muito mosquito
é que eu vou ser muito complicado e eu
sou daquele tipo de pessoas quando é
picado porque assim com aquela batata
gigante sabe mais coisas estranhas aqui
no jardim vejam só os buracos que tem no
chão mas não percebo que buracos não
existe eu não sei se isto parece ser
algo rápido mesmo algum tipo de animal
subterrâneo é eu conto com vocês como em
baixo o que vocês acham que é angel acho
que a culpa era respeito muito e para
quem pergunta no último vídeo que
aconteceu a parceria inclusive achou a
mãe de rui carlos cal ou fugir para
algum lugar porque entretanto não
encontrei mais e ainda teve um bom tempo
à procura dela e não consegui fechar
então a pergunta já vai embora os dados
mostrem um pouco no jardim e as coisas
que não acontecer vamos lá então passar
o nosso sofrimento vai buscar o material
em bom jardim o nosso material satânico
uma frigideira com óleo
os nossos povos um copo de água e chá e
temos aqui o nosso termômetro que usar
para medir a temperatura então o que nós
vamos fazer aqui hoje pessoal eu vou
tentar fazer uma refeição completa ou
seja ovo frito com chazinho para isso
acontecer é muito fácil é só colocar um
refrigerante no chão eo nosso corpo água
espraiada que ser tão bora lá fazer isso
cometem mas também o que vocês acham que
vai resultar assunto chave é a mesma que
ser assunto o ovo vai cozinhar comentou
muito em baixo e por que não só pessoal
este é um dos momentos com base então eu
conseguiria temperatura tudo até mesmo
com link então isso vai funcionar com a
água e agora é só comprar ou lazer pra
água e vamos ver a temperatura da 25
graus
eu acho a gostar 25° a nossa água à
temperatura ambiente está a 25 graus só
com este calor tipo já que se um pouco
mas vamos aquecer mais ok então nós
vamos fazer agora é colocar nossa eu vou
deixar aqui é em outro andar aqui neste
chão e já estou a sentir hawaiana
queimar muito então vamos lá ver a
pintura do chão 47 grãos
só que tomamos foi mais próximas do cope
54 50 graus 51° meu deus só como podem
ver tá muito quente eu acho que 50 graus
já é suficiente para cozinhar o nosso
aqui está nossa frigideira pessoal já
contei um pouquinho
hoje vamos lá então veio a temperatura
da frigideira 40 graus
então eu acho que temos condições pois
foi despedido resultado entretanto
envolvida temperatura eo bc já subiu eu
acho que no início deste vídeo tapa 37°
37 graus ainda que a primeira coisa que
nós vamos fazer já é de colocar um ovo
dentro da frigideira
nós vamos a colocar a virgindade no chão
aquecer o dark energy survey disse e não
é o asfalto e seu chão de sua casa isso
não nos falta o biólogo explicar se
vocês repararem foi lá pra fora o chão
da rua estrada mesmo ela é feita com
alcatrão então tem assim um alto e baixo
relevo isto é muito bom para aderir à
nossa fragilidade
então quanto mais lixo no chão melhor
ela cobra área área de aquecimento da
frigideira tipo eu não sei se vou fazer
entender e não deixa de ser chão da rua
nem pra cá fora a equipe não estava em
casa
como vocês podem ver olha o braço muito
suado o que narra o ródio senhoras como
assim o que há uns tempos com problemas
brasileiros que dá pra colocar um
relógio dentro mas ultimamente no ano
com esse relógio dentro então muita
gente que vê no tipo ficam a olhar a
quem e quando vai perguntar lhe porque
com essas coisas eu erro quando a coisa
mais filosófica que sempre olha só eu
uso de braceletes e relógios porque eu
não discuto encontrou o tupi não é
porque eu gosto mesmo de varzim está a
marcar 59° já subiu a temperatura só
quer salvar a procurar os nossos jogos
o uff com pena e silva que foi doloroso
por seres que jogou o piloto da linha
tokaido aqui um pouco na sombra está
muito quente na própria câmera está a
crescer muito então vamos esperar o que
cerca de meia hora uma hora porque assim
vai crescer mais
enfim vamos pra eu já volto e finalmente
slater 62° meu deus está muito quente
ok eo nosso chata é 3938 coréia quase 40
sua não é por nada mas com estas
temperaturas vai funcionar eu vou chamar
o tempo para mostrar a filmar
kannan o encontro do que 11 haviam
prendido formais não uma opção mágica do
jack sparrow também não construísse uma
montanha-russa pra nós mas aí a volta da
colômbia e isso é uma boa idéia foi não
acreditar que o novo asfalto vai fazer o
ovo no chão sim acho que isso vai lá vai
dar muito mais um filme pornô e agora
vou pedir uma coisa muito líquido tóxico
que só que assim bem devagar a está
quente está muito quente pessoa tem
produzido há pouco estava a 60 graus
agora está 56 vai cozinhar um ovo muito
fácil absoluta muito que ele pudesse
estar aí meu pai passou nem são leão é
que tem que passou aqui ai meu deus eu
eu só não é a sombra antes de colocar no
nosso eu vou provar chaib está bom mas
precisa de açúcar - na hora eu já sei se
eu caísse essa minha melhor assim só
fosse são de time que bebem chá sem
açúcar comentei porque é isso que a
gente olha aí mesmo interesse mas
averbou 3212 já está bom
conseguimos que o alcance que já
funcionou o ataque sempre que você não
chataoui espero que este ano houve
também por lá então colocar o nosso ovo
na frigideira em 321 só quebrar ac ro
calma não aconteceu nada
não aconteceu nada mas reparar lidando
para mim tá tá começando a ficar branca
lhe aquela zona já fica branca então
está a funcionar se vai dar no quesito
um pouco do meu deus espero que isto
funciona cérebro há muito bem agora só
tem que funcionar
vai levar algum tempo a fritar mas eu
acho que vai funcionar se continuarmos e
que a espera vai funcionar então é então
agora é só esperar
oi isso eu não sei se é do vento mas eu
acho que o jogo está a aquecer o oita
que ser fazer comidas aqui imagina fazer
um bicho aqui e eles colocaram logo
diretamente no chão ea o chão estava
quente sem colocar o ovo ou a galinha
então vou ficar uma hora a pessoa já
tenha que mais roubos e agora vamos
tentar fazer é colocar o ovo diretamente
no chão e ver o que acontece visto que
na frigideira está a demorar um pouco
então vamos apostar tanto andré aidan cá
e para lá eu colocar o pé no chão e
wahabita gritar muito volta mari
transporte tudo o que o jornal não olha
321 vai cozinhar não aconteceu nada
o que já está a ficar branco da neve
muito mais rápido porque já de retoque
estudo está 32 graus e só se colocarmos
aqui mesmo já no chão tá 53 caso do
liquida claret
isso é normal mês mas eu acho que a
solução agora é só mesmo dar tempo é só
esperar que vai cozinhar eu tenho
certeza absoluta efe nomes leite é 20
minutos depois vejam só como está o
nosso povo para a itália em branquinho
lisa e este aqui tá quase por incrível
que pareça este quinto mais rápido que
está no chão eu estava aqui há mais
tempo e não há abrigo assim a que mais
tem pesado mas eu acho que a frase era
ter melhor porque ela conta tudo que
investirá preto eo preto absoluto eu
acho que ainda que se mais sol nós vemos
um corte na época é muito tempo que nós
estamos à espera então não convém estar
sempre a gravação fica muito chato antes
ficar bem na foto
agora vamos ao formato contemporâneo e
continuamos o futebol é feito disso a
visão é que o gol
foto efe nomes lei tem que construir um
reencontro dos conflitos boa idéia é
também mandava eu espero que eu faça o
ovo nem você nem engraçado juntaram quem
compra uma bicicleta fazendo compras com
cartões só o que vocês acham todas as de
idéias curva anterior e agora tem o que
vocês acham que eu vou fazer opina um
carrinho de compras nove seqüências tupi
não meu ano agitado dentro do carrinho
de compras da cidade incluindo o
brasileiro foi o panteísmo instrumento
justo tempo havia o escritor vai espera
então em troca além do chip e daí não
isso é muito complexo em consequ6encia
eles voltaram do descanso 9 50
vai ser um brinquedo já foi manter nela
só usamos fortunati já estamos aqui fora
a travesti e os outros já tão mais
cozinhados mas mesmo assim não precisa
mostrar o que eu vou deixar cozinhar
ainda mais que é pra vocês viram efeitos
afinal por que não voltar sempre mostrar
um pouquinho de já não tem graça então
vamos continuar a soprar e desta vez eu
acho que vos prático uma hora eu vou
esperar uma hora vamos ver como vai
ficar
efe am an eu não acredito frito o único
senhor e os dois outros gritaram oco mas
tão bem podres não dá se muito
combustível
acho que o pessoal depois de 4 92 1340
depois de três horas e 40 minutos esse
fica o nosso clube eo é claro ficou
branquinha
mas não parece que esteja cristina o seu
ovo tóxico este aqui e acho que isso é
mais tóxica também no estado esta que
está muito tóxico e estuprar a gente
está muito menos branco este que está
muito mais pois está deixando o caso do
ouro no pan a do ovo informados que
cinco piores nada é isso mesmo acho que
é do homem mas não só missão cumprida
nós conseguimos fritar os jogos no
asfalto mas não fico muito boa minha
intenção mesmo é comer tipo experimentar
o ouvir ficava bom mas eu não vou fazer
isso tóxico
agora eu acho que o medo da radiação
solar explica aqui embaixo da roupa é
suportável é suportável mas não está em
destaque está muito quente aqui nós só
para vocês terem noção de como tá calor
só construir já fique bronzeado
olha só aqui minha cor agora aqui no
branco é cabeça o quinto branca quito
preto mas vamos salvar a justificar por
que construir espero que vocês tenham
gostado aqui deste experimento deu muito
trabalho porque eu tive que esperar em
média duas horas tem que estar sempre a
controlar o ovo mas nós conseguimos
cozinhar o nosso ramo ou então eu também
fui isso obrigado dentro dele participar
também e já sabem só se não for inscrito
no canal eu sou dark inscrevam se vai
ter muito bom agora isso vocês já estão
aqui no canal deixei muito líquido
stereo e se ajuda mesmo muito o youtube
não é na procura de mais vídeos então
isso é muito importante sério ajuda a um
acordo e só fica quem vai até a próxima